many physicists had a heart attack when
we got news from Geneva Switzerland that
Einstein might be wrong all hell broke
loose in the physics community every
physicist I know was taking a position
on this hot topic because relativity is
the foundation of modern physics along
with the quantum theory now what they
found was if you take a beam of
neutrinos from the atom smasher in
Geneva Switzerland shoot the beam
through the mountains from Switzerland
to Italy over a distance of 454 miles
the neutrinos outraced
a light beam by a distance of 60 feet 60
feet over a distance of 454 miles
well that isn't sound like much but to a
physicist this is a disaster it means
that the foundations of modern physics
have to be called into question first it
means that time travel could become
commonplace because as you approach the
speed of light time slows down if you
exceed the speed of light time goes
backwards remember that scene in
Superman 1 when Lois Lane dies and
Superman goes into outer space and we
goes around the planet Earth in the
opposite direction the earth stops and
then rotates in the opposite direction
and then all of a sudden Lois Lane
springs back to life well that kind of
scenario might be possible if the speed
of light is not so special that
particles can exceed the speed of light
not to mention that we'll have to
recalibrate everything the age of the
universe the age of stars the distance
to the stars the basic structure of
modern electronics has to be changed at
GPS nuclear weapons all of that would
have to be recalibrated and rethought
through if Einstein theory of relativity
is wrong so what's the solution of the
problem well the solution of the problem
is obviously they goofed they made a
mistake I remember when I was a grad
student years and years ago at Harvard
my advisor at Harvard was Professor
pound and he had the famous pound
experiment where they shot a light beam
from the top of Jefferson Hall to the
bottom of Jefferson Hall now there was a
rival group a rival group that also did
the same experiment and they had to
calculate the speed of light in the
process they found that the speed of
light actually rose in the morning
peaked at noon time then the speed of
light began to slow down at dinner time
and reached a minimum at midnight Wow
this was shocking the speed of light
which governs the universe all of a
sudden is weighted to lunchtime and
dinnertime so what's the problem the
problem was that this counter experiment
this rival experiment was done outdoors
and the sensors were temperature
dependent and of course it's warmer at
lunchtime and colder at midnight while
professor pounds experiment was done
indoors and therefore didn't have that
kind of variation the lesson here is
systematic errors creep into very
delicate calculations some people think
they found the source of the air how do
we know that from Switzerland to Italy
the distance is 454 miles well you use
GPS right obvious but GPS is a
relativistic system it uses relativity
and some physicists have claimed that
they miss calibrated the distance from
the sensors to the satellite and
satellite back down to Italy a triangle
that one of the legs of the triangle was
miss calibrated in the process of doing
this experiment
now there's another counter example back
in 1987 light from a gigantic supernova
in the Magellanic Clouds hit the planet
Earth and simultaneously with that
neutrinos were detected in gigantic
neutrino detectors in Japan so we had a
double whammy light from a supernova
right near the Milky Way galaxy hitting
there at the same time as neutrinos from
a galaxy at tens of thousands of
light-years from the earth so here's the
rub why should we believe this a certain
experiment over a distance of 454 miles
when over a distance of tens of
thousands of light-years neutrinos and
light beams hit the earth at the same
time that's why many physicists believe
that they must have made a systematic
error someplace and the weak link the
weak link in this whole chain of
reasoning is the GPS system and the GPS
system itself is a relativistic system
so in some sense they're using
relativity to defeat relativity and I
think there's something circular about